so for people who don't know
the last couple years you've been like
building a following on ig doing comedy
[ __ ]
yeah
but give me some of your background
before you decided to do the the
instagram comedy show because you've
been around for a minute like just kind
of in the scene of la and the music [ __ ]
so kind of break down some of your like
how you got kind of introduced into just
the entertainment world man i mean i'm
17 years in doug
you know sounds like 15. right djing
producing this [ __ ] type of [ __ ] you
know
and um like in uh 2000
i want to say six or seven
uh i started really getting like a
little momentum with the music and i had
a record i called industry beefs you
were rapping mm-hmm okay yeah i was
producing rapping my own [ __ ] at the
time you know
this is when like having a studio at
your crib was like a big deal a big deal
yeah you know
and uh i had a record called uh
i had a record called industry beeps and
that caught the ear of uh
steve labelle and shout out to maniac
maniac lobel yeah so mania i mean echo
bell and um uh and shauna lewis
and this around the same time like i
remember when steve had me come over
this house right it was me sean
and steve the bell we were at his house
and i'm sure jamie adler was hanging
around somewhere yeah he was somewhere i
mean crazy story jamie allen saw me
getting arrested
i got arrested at his [ __ ] uh at his
office right there in hollywood
um
so we were at his house yeah you know
and he's like yo man i really you know
like i like your record and you know
thinking about you know hopefully you
know getting to manage you and he's like
yo
i have this other kid
that i want to show you and just let me
know what you think you know and we go
into his garage and he pops you know
pops his record and his this his record
was called um the bulletin got a
bulletin got no name so it was nip
at the time you know it's like nip was
barely like coming up you know yeah and
i remember me and him got signed the
same week to like you know you know to
get managed by the team
and that like that was the beginning of
more or less like me kind of getting my
feet with like in the industry you were
managing how long were you uh managed by
a lobel i was with him for like four
years oh wow mm-hmm that's crazy yeah
seems like fan man that's great yeah
yeah you know so i got to you know get
records with a few of his other artists
like bone thugs and i ass
sean kingston yeah yeah yeah man